et notre invité politique ce matin s'est
Alexis Corbière bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous savez vous députés
de la Seine-Saint-Denis du groupe la
France insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale
on a beaucoup de sujets à voir avec vous
et on commence par le chêne Viking c'est
ce bateau de l'association de l'ONG SOS
Méditerranée qui est actuellement dans
la Méditerranée l'approche les
autoritoriales Françaises avec plus de
200 migrants à son bord la France qui
dénonce le refus inacceptable je cite de
l'Italie de laisser à côté l'Italie doit
jouer son rôle selon le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier Véran quand on sait
vous voilà la France a raison déjà de
dénoncer l'attitude du gouvernement
italien c'est très concret je veux dire
que chacun est en tête si par malheur
Madame Le Pen qui est un peu la
l'équivalent du gouvernement italien
était un responsabilité ça veut dire que
concrètement même le droit international
maritime ne serait pas appliqué parce
que c'est ça dont on parle quel que soit
la position des uns des autres sur
l'immigration à des conventions qui sont
pas ailleurs des traditions très
anciennes mais qui sont notamment
exprimés par des conventions il y en a
une de
qui a des ports éventuellement français
le nom de du port de Toulon était ok qui
puisse accueillir ce bateau
est-ce que le gouvernement français doit
dire oui pour que ce soit le temps de
dire oui voilà il faut le faire on a
trop perdu de temps dansait déjà c'est
tout à l'honneur monsieur Siméoni pour
ce qui est de l'accord de Marseille de
dire bon maintenant on sort d'une
situation où on peut faire un bras de
fer avec le gouvernement italien il
s'agit d'abord de marquer là qui a un
problème je rappelle que Monsieur Macron
était un des premiers à rencontrer
Madame mélonie du serrer la main mettre
sans sel on avait dit bon c'était pour
des raisons diplomatiques mais je vais
dire c'est
l'extrême droite non mais il l'a fait
très en Italie il a fait très rapidement
et bon voilà j'en aurais pu imaginer
autre chose et des déclarations
qu'importe quoi qu'il en soit là
maintenant je crois qu'il est temps on
l'aura comprise mais même s'il fallait
un peu rappeler le cadre d'accueillir
ces gens de leur prêter évidemment le
secours immédiat et d'avoir en tête si
vous permettez que bon première depuis
le début de l'année c'est 1700 personnes
qui sont mortes en Méditerranée on parle
de sujets sérieux que le à la question
des migrations et le grand sujet du 21e
siècle que pour ma part je ne défends
pas l'idée non plus que nous n'ayons pas
des politiques d'immigration plus larges
c'est aux États du monde de voir comment
nous évitons que des millions de gens
soient jetés sur les routes en raison
des dérèglements climatiques des guerres
des traités de libre-échange qui ont
fichier ont l'air des économies mais en
attendant la réponse peut pas être ce
slogan brutal et bestial qu'on a entendu
à l'Assemblée nationale qui retourne en
Afrique j'en ai rien à l'affiche etc
c'est des gens qui sont en situation de
détresse qui risque leur vie et il me
semble que c'est la base de toute
société humaine de toute tradition
politique de toute le conviction
spirituelle que de dire
c'est ce que vous dites ce qui ne doit
pas empêcher une politique migratoire
plus ferme mais qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire plus ferme je ne sais pas
actuellement elle est ferme de toute
manière faut arrêter de faire croire aux
gens
je suis dans un département en plus de
Seine-Saint-Denis où il y a de
l'immigration ou les beaucoup de gens
sont rencontre des tracas administratifs
bon je veux dire c'est que dans l'esprit
de gens qui a du du laxisme c'est pas le
sujet mais de toute manière moi je suis
pour que cette question là parce que je
vois bien des fois le désarroi alors il
y a des des agendas médiatiques qui sont
créés mais c'est une réflexion nous
devons avoir au niveau mondial par
nombre de dire alors je sais bien ça
peut sembler écrasant mais oui pour
quelle raison des gens quittent leur
pays pour quelle raison d'une fois de
plus des économies qui ont eu
fonctionner cette notion de détresse le
dérèglement climatique c'est pas
seulement une obsession d'écolos des
connectés c'est la réponse ok il faut
mondialement et toute la collectivité
humaine mondiale doit apprendre à bras
le corps sinon nous aurons dans le 21e
siècle des millions de gens qui
quitteront leur pays alors à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce qu'on va faire des
barbelés c'est c'est irresponsable donc
c'est un sujet lourd auquel il faut pas
répondre bestialement comme je vous
savais bien à quoi je fais référence
parce que c'est absurde parce que c'est
pour ça que je pousse l'avantage enfin
du moins l'argumentation c'est comme
Madame Le Pen a dit c'est notre
politique mais Adam Le Pen ça va être
comme Madame Meloni terme madame le
maintenant responsabilité va laisser
mourir des gens sur des bateaux c'est ça
qu'elle veut c'est ce sera ça la France
sera un pays qui respectera plus les
conventions internationales maritimes
c'est un pays qui se considéra submerger
parce que de son compte personne en
détresse vont se présenter dans un
bateau c'est ça le pays qu'on veut c'est
quand on est fier d'être français avec
ça moi je ça me révolte tu dis mais bon
sang bien sûr que le sujet complexe mais
la bestialité la brutalité et un peu la
sottise disons-le
la courte vue peut pas être
pour vous pardon ce titre de la part du
RN bah je compte même Madame Le Pen l'a
dit il est pas malin c'est celui qui a
dit ça mais il a révélé comment
dirais-je par un cri bestial aussi une
politique avec lequel moi je ne suis pas
d'accord ce qui ne signifie pas pour
autant qu'il y a pas des sujets sérieux
qu'il faut aborder sur ce thème là on va
passer à un autre sujet mouvement de
grève massif aujourd'hui à la RATP
quasiment pas de métro perturbation sur
les TER sur les RER et dans le même
temps le Parlement a donné son feu vert
à la nomination de Jean Castex à la tête
de la RATP pour vous de la situation non
mais bon pas spécialement non mais par
contre ce dont on parle c'est d'une
privatisation
de des services de transport notamment
en Île-de-France qui amène à une
réduction du nombre de litres notamment
moi je le vis très concrètement je suis
élu sensei Bagnolet c'est des lignes de
bus en moins qui ont lieu aujourd'hui et
ce qui amène à ce que les usagers vous
savez souvent ceux qui sont pas en
région parisienne c'est peut-être un peu
abstrait mais selon de la proximité du
métro vous avez un rapport totalement
différent à l'agglomération etc alors
c'est lignes de bus après qui sont
indispensables pour que les gens se
rendent au travail si vous en avez 10 %
qui sont supprimés ça veut dire qu'on
passe après de 15 minutes 20 minutes
d'attente etc ça complique tout et ça
c'est des politiques qui sont mis en
place et en changement de statut
vis-à-vis des agents c'est plus de
travail qui va être fait évidemment
c'est une dégradation de leurs
conditions de travail c'est donc une
défense du service public qui motive la
grève aujourd'hui et ils ont raison de
la région Île-de-France qui demande à
RATP de revenir à ça l'offre d'avant COV
100% de l'offre avant covid et qui
appelle Jean Castex a rétablir une
qualité de service qui s'est nettement
dégradée vous la soutenez dans cet appel
Valérie Pékin le mouvement de
privatisation puis elle évoque même la
possibilité que le Pass Navigo soit
augmenté pour trouver des marges de
manœuvre financière donc il faut mener
la bataille pour que ce ne soit pas les
usagers qui s'en retrouve aujourd'hui
les principaux dire ce qui payent cette
augmentation donc je ne fais pas
confiance pour des choses clairement
madame Pécresse pour défendre le service
public vu qu'elle a elle-même entamé la
marche à la privatisation du service
public vous qui parlez justement de la
vie chère de pouvoir d'achat il y aurait
une suite à votre marche contre la vie
chère du 16 octobre il le faudrait il le
faudrait nous en discutons il y a pas de
date de date qui sont fixés vous savez
que nous avons aussi en dialogue avec
les organisations syndicales dans le
respect de chacun pourquoi pas à ce que
tout converge dans une seule et même
journée c'est parfois accueilli de
manière un peu certains des
organisations syndicales
oui on a réfléchi là dans le calendrier
qui est notre on essaie aussi de voir
pour être franc avec vous l'agenda un
peu social hier par exemple j'étais avec
d'autres parlementaires à l'invitation
de Monsieur duob au ministère du Travail
la réforme des retraites qui est en
cours c'est aussi un sujet politique qui
va de pair avec le fait de l'inflation
de la dégradation de ce qu'on appelle la
vie chère c'est à dire aussi la
possibilité la volonté de ce gouvernance
de faire frapper des Français plus
longtemps de reporter l'âge de retraite
jusqu'à 65 ans qui entraînerait selon
nous une baisse des pensions évidemment
je rappelle qu'on a le taux
d'employabilité le plus bas à partir de
50-55 ans et comment croire le fait de
repousser en plus l'âge de déclenchement
de la retraite que ça va créer quelque
chose de positif donc là de nouvelles
marches contre la vie chère mais que
vous réfléchissez à une mobilisation
de répliquer de se mobiliser oui et que
nous regardons un peu comment le
gouvernement lui-même avance pour
éventuellement être comment dirais-je
raccord avec ce qui se passe parce qu'il
quoi se mobiliser très fortement contre
ça en fait du moins nous nous y appelons
à se mobiliser ce serait une gigantesque
régression sociale que personne ne croit
que ça va être quelque chose qui va
améliorer la vie des gens ça va
entraîner je le répète de plus en plus
de Français qui n'arriveront pas à avoir
la totalité de leur trimestre qui
subiront une décote déjà du point de vue
de la retraite qui subiront le fait
qu'ils n'auront pas la totalité de leur
trimestre et on aura des pensions plus
basses on va avoir des retraités pauvres
et moi je ne veux pas de ça content à ce
qu'affiant le ministre c'est une mesure
en fait purement d'économie budgétaire
qui va aller dans le sens d'une
dégradation sociale pas que parce que
René Paul Savary qui était là juste
avant vous de sénateur de droit de
rapporteur de ce sujet au Sénat il dit
que de toute façon avec la réforme
Touraine votée par la gauche sous un
gouvernement socialiste on arrive à un
report de l'âge de départ qu'est-ce que
vous dites de ça est-ce qu'il y a pas un
peu une forme d'hypocrisie de la part de
la gauche alors vous aurez remarqué que
je ne suis pas socialiste et que ce qui
fait partenaire
et ce qui fait un peu ma singularité
justement c'est que nous sommes en
rupture avec les politiques qui ont été
menées en particulier par cette qualité
par Madame Touraine là aussi ce que vous
dites et vous avez bien raison et encore
sujet de discussion en particulier avec
mes amis sénateurs socialiste parce que
je le rappelle que pour ce qui est de la
nupaisse nous avons passé un accord en
accord programmatique dans lequel le mot
d'ordre qui est retenu c'est celui
d'aller de retourner vers la retraite à
60 ans d'accord c'est ça sur lequel nous
nous sommes rassemblés alors je sais
bien que ça fait peut-être discussion de
la part de certains qui ont pas
totalement comment dirais digérer la
réalité de cet accord mais il est là il
est son nom et trébuchant et c'est ça
qui a permis que nous ayons 150 députés
à l'Assemblée nationale
au parlementaire socialiste de défendre
la retraite à 60 ans
nupes que nous avons mis en place si
nous l'avons signé les gens qui l'ont
signé sont des gens sérieux et
effectivement ça passe par une rupture
avec les réformes Touran qui de mon
point de vue ne vont pas évidemment dans
le bon sens c'est ce qui a amené à ce
que Monsieur Hollande à responsabilité
n'a jugé impossible de se représenter
pour la suite c'est à dire combien ces
réformes sociales étaient jugées comment
dire positivement par les Français donc
faut que tout le monde est un peu en
mémoire les choses ça n'est pas excessif
ça n'a rien d'incroyable que de se dire
qu'on revient à ce qu'il faisait partie
des grandes conquêtes sociales de la
gauche en 1981 quand elle est revenue
quand elle est enfin accéder en
responsabilité les gens n'ont besoin
c'est ce qui permettrait des millions de
gens et des pensions de retraite digne
et que en fait on puisse profiter je le
répète que l'âge en bonne santé c'est
62,3 ans pour les gens et si on veut
profiter de cette nouvelle étape de la
vie de la retraite c'est pas déglinguer
cassé c'est pouvoir un peu en bénéficier
parce que le droit aussi après avoir
bien travaillé à tranquillité au bonheur
à se consacrer à des tas de choses sa
propre famille ou des activités diverses
c'est un semble-t-il la marque d'une
humanité d'une société humaine mais
puisque vous parlez des différences avec
les socialistes il y a deux jours
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté le budget
aux rectificatif avec les mesures
pouvoir d'achat le chèque énergie la
ristombe sur les carburants adopter 149
3 parce qu'il y a eu abstention DLR et
des députés socialistes vous le
regrettez non ça c'est encore c'est pas
l'aspect bonjour peut-être ça aurait été
mieux qu'on voit tous ensemble mais
comme dans ce PLFR il y avait eu
quelques avancées malgré tout la
discussion contre je veux dire à une
forme de pertinence à mes yeux j'ai plus
de désert
de discussion entre nous quand il s'agit
de voter la motion de censure moi je
pense que mes amis socialistes auraient
dû la voter comme nous ils ont préféré
s'abstenir là je vous parle librement et
Olivier fort le sait là je pense qu'on
aurait dû tous se retrouver sur la
motion censure sur le PLFR nous on a
voté compte sont abstenus mais certains
ont voulu marquer le fait que dans la
discussion il y a eu des des choses où
on a voté contre avec les écologistes et
les communistes c'est là il y a pas il y
a pas de tension particulière et vous
continuerez déposer des notions de
censure à chacun écouter madame la
Première ministre veut banaliser
l'utilisation du 49-3 je ne vois pas
pourquoi on devrait politiquement c'est
des face à elle et dire finalement vous
avez raison allez-y continue il faut pas
banaliser la notion de censure pour
quelle raison Madame la première année
je banalise le 49-3 et nous on y
répondrait pas puis en fait je vais vous
dire une chose hormis des parlementaires
les Français moi de ce que je vois il
trouve ça normal qu'un député
d'opposition s'oppose qui me fait
reproche en disant je dis pas que ça
passionne tous les gens mais les gens
qui suivent
avec une motion de censure a été déposée
que ce même par des socialistes il y
avait parfois des Front National qui
votaient et ça ne ça ne faisait
s'évanouir personne c'est la marque
d'une motion de censure vous la déposez
vous ne proposez pas un contrat de
gouvernement vous dites seulement voilà
je veux censurer et des gens pour plein
de raisons différentes peuvent amener à
censurer ce gouvernement et c'est la
moindre des choses c'est normal vous ou
alors c'est la motion censure d'opérette
je dépose une notion de censure mais
surtout ne la votez pas parce que nous
avons des désaccords politiques ça c'est
le théâtre de guignols et les Français
qui regarderaient ça dirait en fait vous
êtes des gens inconséquent moi je pense
que quand je dépose une notion de
censure c'est pour qu'elle gagne pour
censurer le gouvernement monsieur Macron
a dit si c'est majoritaire je dissurer
la saint national et bien on lui dit
chiche moi j'ai pas peur des électeurs
s'ils font repasser par là revenons aux
urnes je ne subis je ne je ne comment
dirais je ne vais pas céder cesser
d'être opposante sous les menaces de je
ne sais trop qui ou le qu'en dira-t-on
inventé uniquement je le répète par des
gens minoritaires dans le Parti
socialiste mais qui veulent mettre à mal
la stratégie d'Olivier fort de faire
l'union avec nous donc c'est des
arguments de mauvaise foi porté par des
gens j'ai même vu que monsieur
Cambadélis ressortant de sa boîte comme
d'un seul coup venir nous expliquer des
choses qui dû trouver tout à fait normal
quand il dirigeait le Parti socialiste
et même monsieur Darmanin nous évoque
critiqué quand monsieur Darmanin et a eu
voté d'émotions de censure avec le
rassemblement national donc leur
mauvaise foi montre que en 5e République
quand tu déposes une notion de censure
j'invite les députés LR j'invite tous
ceux qui le souhaitent à censurer le
gouvernement et il n'y a aucun pacte de
gouvernement ni aucun compromis et je
termine ma démonstration sur une chose
qui était même question que le texte de
la motion de censure qui accompagne le
dépôt de la motion de censure aurait
fait des concessions pour que le
rassemblement national le vote c'est
totalement faux à tel point même que la
dernière motion de censure que vous en
portée pour tes mêmes j'ai plus à
phrases en tête pardon mais des
critiques design du RN et le RN l'a
quand même voté je vais pas citer des
noms mais il y a des députés à son
national que j'ai eu une fois qu'ils ont
dit quel que soit ce que vous maîtriez
dedans on la votera donc tout ça c'était
uniquement une volonté interne et
politicienne mais sur le fond s'il faut
faire chuter ce gouvernement qui va
faire travailler les Français plus
longtemps qui propose des mauvais
budgets qui décrent des services publics
nous sommes pour ça on va parler d'un
chiffre qui a été publié c'est le
chiffre des attentes la laïcité au sein
des établissements scolaires 720 car
recensés au mois d'octobre c'était 313
en septembre et 40% des incidents le son
pour port de signe est tenues
religieuses ce sont des chiffres qui
vous inquiète alors ce sujet
premièrement la laïcité et quelque chose
d'important moi je suis favorable à la
loi de 2004 qui interdit le port des
signes religieux à l'école je rappelle
au passage que je avant d'être par le
long terme je suis prof d'histoire en
lycée professionnel etc donc bon alors
une fois qu'on a dit ça premièrement
attention à ce que ces chiffres moi j'ai
demandé au ministre des précisions soit
pas des chiffres du fait que il n'y a
pas en soi d'augmentation mais il y a
plutôt une demande de plus en plus
importante de la part des fois du
rectorat il y a eu des chefs
d'établissement de faire remonter tout
ce qui se passe d'accord alors ça
peut-être que pour les gens qui nous
écoutent
ce que je veux dire c'est est-ce que la
situation se moque augmentation
situation qui sont plus signalées je
demande à ce que il y ait pas du sens
analyse du sensationnalisme autour des
chiffres en fait il y a un autre sujet
et mettre les pieds dans le plat les
signes religieux je sais ce que c'est
mais un vêtement
culturel est-ce que c'est un signe
religieux et une discussion qui est pas
simple et moi il faut en avoir un peu
parlé y compris et que le ministre et
autres c'est que comment on légifère sur
une tenue pas sur un signe religieux je
sais ce qui est une qui parle je sais ce
qui est en foulard je sais ce qui a une
croix d'accord mais une tenue
vous rentrez là dans quelque chose qui
est la police du vêtement et ça c'est
pas la laïcité c'est pas Aristide Briand
arrêtez de brillant 1905 est très clair
là-dessus et je le rappelle pour ceux
qui avaient suivi ou du moins ce qui est
en relu quand en 1905 sous la pression
de ceux qui étaient les plus antiques
les Rico de l'hémicycle des gens qui me
sont assez sympathiques par ailleurs qui
demandaient à ce que même la soutane
soit interdite Aristide Briand répondait
la Bible TD des des couturiers et des
tailleurs sera toujours un même de
trouver une autre manière d'exprimer de
toute manière une proximité
confessionnelle donc on peut pas aller
là-dessus et donc je demande à pas des
tenues qui sont quand même
significatives de quoi j'allais dire
d'une appartenance culturelle oui sans
doute oui et alors religieuse une
appartenance culturelle et c'est on est
dans le flou mais comment légifère en
interdit des tenues et ça retrouve
demain à l'heure il y aura une religion
qui va dire tel jour on s'habille de
blanc parce que et alors on va interdire
une couleur ça s'arrête tout ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est facile de
jouer des muscles et dire attention mais
ça s'arrête tout tout ça qu'on légifère
comme législateur qu'est-ce qu'on fait
vraiment est-ce que c'est vraiment ça la
laïcité est-ce que c'est la tenue d'une
robe moi
clarifications à faire en tant que
législateur pour vous je pense que là on
s'aventure sur un terrain et je demande
à voir qui ne va certainement rien donné
si ce n'est agité des chiffres moi je
répète que pas de signe religieux dans
l'établissement scolaire sans aucun
doute pas de pression religieuse
évidemment sur l'enseignement sans aucun
doute et avec fermeté et il faut
sanctionner quiconque a fortiori si
c'est des gens extérieurs aux
établissements et des parents qui
viennent
un enseignant d'avoir fait cours là je
suis pour non mais là
est-ce que les profs sont suffisamment
protégés sont
suffisamment reconnaissés on est deux
ans après l'affaire Samuel Paty c'est
quelque chose de plus abject et bestial
qui est plus exister mais même au-delà
de ça moi j'ai pas de chiffres mais
c'est sans doute une réalité je sais
bien que il y a parfois des gens qui
s'emportent et des parents plein
d'obscurantisme qui viennent expliquer
que ce qui est enseigné et contraire à
leur conviction spirituelle et on doit
les laisser clairement leur dire il
n'avait pas question que quicon soit
menacé ça c'est une chose sur lequel
faut être ferme mais là après ce dont on
parle c'est la manière dont bien souvent
des jeunes adolescents s'habillent et je
ne vois j'ai peur par exemple c'est pas
religieux pour vous non c'est pas aussi
une religieux non mais du coup je suis
pas un spécialiste de l'islam mais c'est
ça indiscutablement un vêtement qui est
dans comment dirais-je la sphère
culturelle
du Maghreb et des pays musulmans mais ça
n'est pas à ma connaissance un signe
religieux donc c'est délicat vous
comprenez ce que je suis en train de
dire c'est à dire que je veux pas qu'on
soit contre-productif c'est à dire que
notre but aussi à nous c'est d'enseigner
la laïcité qui est une manière de dire
que c'est la liberté de conscience et
donc la liberté de de de pouvoir
pratiquer sa religion qu'évidemment ce
qui est la marque ostensible d'une
appartenance religieuse c'est une chose
mais si après on rentre sur des domaines
qui sont plus maîtrisés uniquement pour
en gros dire il y a comment dirais-je on
est dans un pays dans le calcul
littéralement on s'habille une certaine
façon je veux dire je crois qu'on
s'aventure vers des choses qui sont
l'exacerbation mais pour terminer
pendant ce que par contre les
enseignants moi je le sais et c'était
déjà le cas quand j'étais en
responsabilité vous savez la vraie
formation sur la laïcité des profs ils
sont ramenés à peu de choses les profs
font leur demande énormément d'efforts
en leur demandant d'enseigner la laïcité
mais en leur donne pas les outils pour
pouvoir le faire c'est un peu
débrouillez-vous et puis après quand il
y a une tension aussi une administration
parfois et même une haute administration
qui ne les aide pas nécessairement donc
c'est pas simple et moi je pense qu'on
aurait tout à gagner à former plus les
profs à les aider à accompagner ça quel
est le choix du document pédagogique
quelle discussion vont mener qu'est-ce
qu'on veut véritablement leur apprend
que en permanence être dans une
agitation qui ne crée pas toujours de la
conscience voilà où j'en suis
votre partie parce que la dernière fois
que vous êtes venu vous nous avez dit
que il fallait réfléchir à une
réorganisation que c'était en cours
suite évidemment au retrait quand même
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon on en est où cette
réorganisation de la France insoumise
une convention qui va avoir lieu je
crois le 11 décembre ou tout va être
annoncé peut-être un peu avant ça
s'organise ça discute permettait un peu
que effectivement ça se discute entre
nous de quelle manière une nouvelle
organisation une nouvelle direction plus
plus visible du point de vue de tous
ceux qui sont nos sympathisants et
militants se mettent en place ou alors
on en est là tranquillement
la chose possible qu'il y a quelqu'un
qui coordonne mais il y aura une équipe
il y a plusieurs candidats non non
plus assez administratif on va dire
c'est pas toi ce qui m'intéresse et vous
dites la France
on rentre dans une étape nouvelle déjà
on est passé de 17 députés à 75 députés
beaucoup de gens nouveaux il faut former
aussi moi je suis pour vous savez la
bataille qu'on a amené elle est
culturelle elle idéologique tout ce dont
on parle que ce soit la manière dont
progresse parfois ce que fait le
gouvernement enfin la manière dont il
marque des points ou pas dans l'opinion
la manière dont l'ex qu'on voit de
progresser des imaginaire politique qui
ne sont imposés de la menace de
l'immigration de fait qu'il y a des gens
feignants dans ce pays etc et beaucoup
d'autres sujets donc moi je suis très
attaché aux bataille culturelles
c'est-à-dire réexpliquer je pense que
nous devons polariser des intellectuels
pourquoi pas des conférences thématiques
assez régulièrement autour de sujets
pour montrer qu'une autre société est
possible que ce qui est comment
dirais-je conforme à l'histoire de la
France et une histoire républicaine
démocratique d'avancer des droits dans
lequel les citoyens prend toute sa place
c'est quoi la souveraineté etc bon tout
nombre de sujets on pourrait en aborder
d'autres ça je pense qu'on peut le faire
on peut le faire avec beaucoup d'autres
moyens mais parce qu'on a beaucoup
grandi et il faut y travailler voilà
il va revenir à l'Assemblée il faudra
qu'il revienne oui
c'est pas totalement tranché mais avouez
que c'est quand même délicat cette
histoire derrière il a été élu par des
gens il a fait quelque chose qui est
condamnable mais aussi aussi à la
justice de le dire il n'a rien caché je
veux dire il a immédiatement il a même
fait état presque trop à mon goût de
choses qu'il a écrit qui sont pas leur
sa version qui est pas la vraie version
il aurait pas dû dévoiler sa version
publiquement qu'il devait garder sa
parole pour la justice je dis pas parce
que c'est mon ami mais de manière
générale au bout d'un moment quand la
justice est saisie sur quelque chose en
plus on parle de l'intime et bien que
par contre faut répondre à la justice
évidemment mais pas la peine mais moi
cette obscénité médiatique auquel on a
droit aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je ne
crois pas qu'il faut le faire parce que
ça n'apporte rien parce que vous avez le
regard de quelqu'un vous avez évidemment
je pense à son épouse ou à son ex-épouse
je sais pas comment la qualifié
aujourd'hui à Céline que je connais par
ailleurs moi je connais tous les les
acteurs si je peux tout ça c'est des
gens que que j'aime qui se déchire on a
tout ça dans nos vies et je crois pas
que ce soit utile d'un seul coup qui est
comme ça une mise en vitrine de moi je
pense ça je m'inversion ça sert à rien
par la justice doit travailler mais elle
prend du temps et en attendant je vois
pas pourquoi quelqu'un qui qu'on irait à
une attitude qui est quand même correcte
du point de vue de une cache rien qui
reconnaît des choses il peut continuer à
faire le boulot mais c'est donc il doit
revenir à l'Assemblée on verra comment
après c'est prévu qu'il revienne avant
la fin du mois il y a rien d'établi mais
effectivement je veux dire il y a une
réflexion la présidente du groupe a fait
savoir dans le groupe il y avait une
réflexion qui était engagée moi je veux
pas que ce soit la chasse à l'homme non
plus fait le zoo c'est à dire que quand
il vient immédiatement il y a 80 de vos
collègues qui lui sautent dessus pour
savoir il fallait qu'il faut que ce soit
un peu digne tout ça et par ailleurs
aussi là j'ai pas tous les éléments
c'est peut-être que si la justice
pouvait peut-être s'exprimer avant ça ça
peut aider à ce qui est des
clarifications pour la suite je moi je
ne sais pas le calendrier judiciaire
mais vous réfléchissez à son retour
d'ici Adrien honnêtement il a eu un coup
de mou pardon de l'expression aussi
pendant un moment il était pas en
situation personnelle affective
de remonter sur le cheval si je puis
dire il est en arrêt maladie il est
encore là je crois que ça commence
maintenant il commence un peu à remettre
mais c'était pas simple parce que
beaucoup de choses dans sa vie
personnelle il y a une enfant en bas âge
au milieu il y a beaucoup de choses qui
étaient douloureuses là je pense qu'il
est en situation intellectuelle
maintenant de de revenir c'est du moins
ce qui semble dire il y a des combats à
mener il y a des gens qui l'ont élu moi
je crois qu'il faut travailler dans cet
esprit là mais dans le respect aussi
c'est pas rien ce qui a eu lieu il y a
une sensibilité assez question là et des
combats que nous menons contre les
violences faites aux femmes donc faut
trouver le juste équilibre et quelque
chose qui est compréhensible
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
on passe au club des territoires
[Musique]